Der klimawandel ist da und er wird uns wohl mit noch voller breitseite erwischen aber
Bereits heutzutage hat der katastrophale auswirkung und zwar nicht nur für natur und tiere sondern vor allem auch für uns menschen
Weltweit aber auch in deutschland und das schlimme ist der klimawandel ist durch uns verursacht worden
Ja ihr habt euch das thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt die
Krassesten folgen die es heute schon zu sehen gibt also herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
Krankheiten breiten sich aus durch den klimawandel werden sich krankheiten ausbreiten wenn logisch
krankheitsüberträger wie etwa anopheles stechmücke aber auch nagetiere und zugvögel die krankheiten übertragen
Mögen es eher warm und feucht durch eine erhöhte temperatur
Verbessern sich also ihre lebensbedingungen und diese erhöhte temperatur die gibt es jetzt schon aber das ist nur eine folge des klimawandels
Auch die allergiker unter uns also etwa 20 bis 30 prozent der deutschen werden zunehmend leiden denn durch den menschengemachten
klimawandel kommt es wohl dazu dass pflanzen früher austreiben und blühen pflanzen die allergenes potenzial
Haben werden sich zudem weiter ausbreiten und als wäre das nicht
genug wird wohl auch noch das trinkwasser knapp schon jetzt sorgen kaymer in warmen und ärmeren regionen der erde zu
krankheiten wie cholera
Im schlimmsten fall sogar zu epidemien und es sterben jedes jahr vier millionen menschen weil sauberes trinkwasser nicht in
ausreichender menge verfügbar ist durch den erwarteten
temperaturanstieg den der klimawandel mit sich bringen wird wird das problem zukünftig noch größer durch den anstieg des meeresspiegels
könnte zudem auch das grundwasser versalzen werden und durch die mögliche überflutung von mülldeponien
wird sauberes wasser noch knapper die luftverschmutzung steigt enorm studien erwarten in den nächsten jahren extreme hitzewellen als folge des klimawandels
Mit der starken sonneneinstrahlung und den hohen temperaturen bildet sich aus sogenannten vorläufersubstanzen
bodennahes ozon
unterschieden wird zwischen dem harmlosen stratosphärischen ozon das uns ja sogar vor schädlichen uv-strahlen schützt und dem
Troposphäre ozon das ist ein
luftschadstoff der in der menschlichen lunge
zu krassen scheffelt und das ist echt nicht ohne europäische studien ergaben einen zusammenhang zwischen der täglichen
sterberate und der höhe der ozonkonzentration
Die sterberate stieg um 0,3 prozent pro zehn mikrogramm je kubikmeter
also zehn millionstel gramm
pro kubikmeter anstieg das wetter wird immer extremer die letzten jahre waren hinsichtlich der weltweiten temperaturen
rekordverdächtig nicht nur
2014 2015 und 2016 sondern vor allem auch
2007 zehn waren
außergewöhnlich laut der weltwetterorganisation wmo
haben hat die temperatur
1,1 grad über dem vorindustriellen wert gelegen mit dabei außerdem temperaturen von mehr als 50 grad celsius in asien
Rekordhöhe cans in der karibik und im atlantik sowie eine sehr lange dürre in afrika und ja
lange zeit haben sich geber forschungsteams schwergetan solche extreme wetterphänomene
In einen direkten zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel zu bringen doch mittlerweile
machen schnelle computer und optimierte klimamodelle das möglich und tatsächlich
Fiel der eben aufgezählten wetterereignisse lassen sich mit, hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
auf den klimawandel zurück führen in einer großen studie
Haben 33 forschungsteams aus der ganzen welt wetterphänomene
Im jahr 2014 analysiert die entscheidende frage waren die extremen wetterereignisse von 2014 auf
natürliche schwankungen
im klimasystem zurückzuführen oder waren sie tatsächlich folgen des menschengemachten
klimawandels thomas kahl einer der beteiligten forscher mit dem fazit wir können
demonstrieren dass einzelne ereignisse sowie temperatur extreme oft mit den von uns
zusätzlich in die atmosphäre
gepumpten treibhausgasen verknüpft sind andere extreme darunter regenfälle sind weniger eindeutig auf den klimawandel und
menschliche einflüsse zurückzuführen der klimawandel hat also durchaus einfluss auf die häufigkeit und spannbreite von solchen extremereignissen
Im jahr 2014 beispielsweise macht man ihn verantwortlich für die hitzerekorde in europa
china argentinien und korea und auch für die lange dürre in ostafrika
Die starken regenfälle, im winter
2013/14 in großbritannien und die winterstürme seien dagegen nicht
eindeutig auf den klimawandel zurückzuführen und in zukunft wird das wetter immer nur noch extremer werden dazu
Heiko paeth von der universität würzburg wenn man in der bodennahen atmosphäre mehr energie hat weil die
treibhausgaskonzentrationen gestiegen sind und einen höheren wärme gehalt in den unteren atmosphärenschichten
Bedingen dann sollte man alleine vom standpunkt der physikalischen plausibilität davon ausgehen dass es in zukunft mehr
Extreme ereignisse gibt der meeresspiegel steigt und nimmt uns unser zuhause erst vor kurzem hat die nasa ein
Echte katastrophenmeldung herausgegeben neue kartierungen zeigen dass deutlich mehr gletscher grönlands von einer schmelze bedroht sind als bisher angenommen nämlich
Zwei bis viermal so viele gletscher wie bislang
angenommen und das hat fatale folgen der meeresspiegel wird stärker und schneller ansteigen als bisher vorhergesagt
Nasa vertreter george will es sagt
Diese ergebnisse zeigen dass das eis in grönland stärker vom klimawandel bedroht ist als wir erwartet hatten
Selbst eine geringe globale erwärmung hat wohl dramatische konsequenzen für das eis in grönland berechnung zufolge ist es schon heute
So dass die eisschmelze in grönland stärker zum anstieg des meeresspiegels?
Beiträgt als die schmelze der antarktis eine komplette gletscherschmelze grönlands hätte
weitreichende folgen nach den neuen berechnungen würde der meeresspiegel dann um
7,4 zwei meter ansteigen und auch wenn grönland sehr weit von uns entfernt ist
Werden vor allem wir in deutschland aber auch die niederlande und belgien sehr stark betroffen seien genauso wie menschen in vielen anderen ländern dieser welt
Indonesien ägypten bangladesch oder thailand wenn der meeresspiegel nur um einen halben bis ganzen meter steigt würde
Der lebensraum zahlreicher menschen komplett unter wasser stehen es gibt berechnungen nachdem bereits. Im jahr
2050 der prozess des abschmelzens
unwiderruflich in gang gesetzt worden sein wird wenn sowohl das grönländische inlandeis
Und auch die antarktis eiskappe komplett schmelzen würden würde der meeresspiegel um 70 meter
ansteigen eine absolut unfassbare vorstellung auch hier berlin wäre unter wasser
Und schon jetzt passiert in teilen der welt der reinste horror durch den anstieg des meeresspiegels sind
im pazifik mindestens acht ganze inseln verschwunden für immer betroffen sind inseln der
salomonen einem inselstaat in der südsee und auch mikronesien ein inselstaat
im westlichen pazifischen ozean in beiden regionen liegt der anstieg des meeresspiegels
Weit über dem durchschnitt dort wurde nämlich sogar ein jährlicher anstieg von 1,2
zentimetern gemessen abgesehen davon dass ihre heimat inseln eine große historische bedeutung für ihre bewohner haben
Sind die menschen dort die 2 alles aufzugeben sie müssen also entweder in höhere regionen
umsiedeln oder aber ihr leben an einem anderen ort komplett neu anfangen eine wirklich traurige entwicklung die menschen stehen vor
Existenzbedrohenden fragen wie was passiert mit uns und unserer heimat wo können wir hin
Wie können wir überleben was passiert mit unserer kultur werden wir jetzt teil eines anderen staates und werden wir dort akzeptiert so wie wir sind
Und die zukunft für die insel im pazifischen ozean sieht nicht gut aus sechs weitere inseln dieser
Insel ketten sind ebenfalls kurz davor vom meer verschluckt, zu werden so die traurige bilanz des forschungsteams glück
Im unglück dass diese zumindest ungewohnt sind und kein menschenleben
direkter gefahr ausgesetzt ist aber auch andere kleine inselstaaten wie die
marshallinseln und die bewohner der malediven
beispielsweise denen droht dieses katastrophenszenario
Und die erosion der küsten ist nur ein problem von vielen dass mehr wasser vergiftet ja auch das ackerland und nimmt den menschen
Ihre nahrungsgrundlage an den betroffenen orten wachsen oft nicht
Mal mehr kokospalmen nicht umsonst gibt es die so genannte allianz kleiner inselstaaten ein zusammenschluss von rund 40 inseln und küsten
Nationen die in ihrer existenz bedroht sind auch orte an denen wir gerne urlaub machen sind dabei zum beispiel die dominikanische
republik kuba die seychellen oder die fidschi-inseln es gibt studien die
prognostizieren dass, im jahr
2100 ein fünftel der weltbevölkerung
klimaflüchtlinge sind das sind 1,5 milliarden
überflutete küstenregionen sorgen diesem szenario nach für eine massenflucht ins landesinnere
wo dann nutzbare flächen viel
zu knapp werden nahrungsmittel würden knapp
durch den klimawandel werden sich temperatur und niederschlag in vielen regionen der erde verändern und damit auch das wachstum der meisten kulturpflanzen
ernteverluste wird es wohl vor allem in den niederen breiten geben, zudem werden wohl auch pflanzenkrankheiten
Die landwirtschaft shading betroffen sind dann mal wieder die eh schon armen länder der welt die schon jetzt gegen unterernährung und überbevölkerung
Kämpfen und wie gerade erwähnt worden durch die geflüchteten aus den überschwemmten gebieten
Wird der platz knapp mehr als erstes neues zum thema klimawandel und zu allen anderen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video und zur begrüßung gibt es auch ein kleines
Goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter damit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker endgültig widerlegt ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran